surtout quand bear elle a besoin de
repos psychiatre c'est vraiment de la
même voix la
voix la laddh s'est marié du voyage ça
s'est passé le 9 juin dernier à los
angeles à l'épousé qui s'amassent halak
avec
marie garrigues et son prof de tennis
on est où
ma
[Musique]
non
faux rythme et malheureusement n'a plus
autant d'argent qu'avant lui resterait
que 60 millions de dollars et la maison
du coup comme elle n'a plus beaucoup de
trésorerie elle a fait énormément de
partenariat pour ce mariage d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'on la voit aujourd'hui
sur les réseaux après le mariage a
remercié les prestataires à faire
beaucoup de story pour sa robe pour les
décorateurs etc etc on appelle ça bad et
des partenariats il faut quand même
relevé le mauvais goût de ce mariage
entre tous les bisous pour tourner là la
calèche de disneyland ya une mini jupe
rouge
cemagref de prince héritier
icône donatella versace alors vous
barrymore a droit
selena gomez ne dit pas oui madonna
voire amendé
harris et donatella alors oui paris s'il
tonne et
brad pitt et marion cotillard se verrait
en secret et ça ce sont des informations
closer par ces boîtes et d'histoire
alors sur ce plateau parce qu'on en
avait déjà parlé dans closer au mois de
février dernier brad pitt était à paris
ou souvenait de rien s'il avait même eu
un rendez vous secret avec jennifer
aniston oui c'était vues à l'hôtel
costes appelé 14 février n'est pas sain
voilà seulement il s'était fait sa
petite visite culturelle avec roselyne
bachelot lourds etc et on a appris
récemment que dans son calendrier très
chargé il avait accordé un petit bout de
son temps à marion cotillard fois dans
le haut péninsule à un bel hôtel
parisien parce qu'il est dans le cognac
l1 sont restés très proches à louis-ii
nuit à 6 ans sur un film un film de
rohmer du robert zemeckis où ils ont
tourné tous les deux depuis sont restés
très proches ils s'appellent beaucoup
quand ils peuvent se voir il se voit et
à qui on va faire croire quand même que
le mec revient à paris ils voient que
des bombes il revoit jennifer aniston
dans un hôtel l'hôtel costes le 14
février hôtels chambres 14 février
ils ont alors mis les pieds de données
warner a partagé le tout premier cliché
de craine gosling dans le rôle de ken
loach est une barbie qui va sortir il va
donner la réplique à margot robbie dans
les films barbie bah ça sera en juillet
2023 ils en référaient ce que ça sera
super bien parce que ça plaise à long
terme on peut en classe pour les deux en
braille c'est réussi savoir que sa part
est de la merde à
quel moment tu te dis je vais aller voir
ken et barbie bas
cible
et que peuvent-ils faire un jugement
comment aurait-il pu arriver une autre
conclusion que sarine aussi sont restées
assez dense et 16 ils ont écouté plus de
trois semaines de témoignages
étaient manège incessant de la part
d'employés payés
vers la fin des gens au hasard c'est
quand même un pays de foot on sort d'une
première instance en mai non les jurés
d'abord on doit rentrer chez de soin
d'en garder tik tok elle donne des
interviews alors qu'elle donne te
rappelle évidemment elle dit qu'elle
aime encore et que peut-être même les
juges tous à l'avocat c'est mignon mais
sur pense que c'est une manipulatrice
exactement et jetons aux etats unis ils
monnaient il les interviews maintenant
qu'elle a son amende à payer il faut
bien qu'à leur week-end pascal c'est
beaucoup beaucoup d'interviews payé par
abbott voilà pour économiser pour payer
non mais je crois surtout qu'amber elle
a besoin de repos pardon de quoi de
repos lorsque site web si cammas est
brillant mais la même voix la mairie et
elle a lâché la rampe
je suis atteint du syndrome que l'on
appelle le syndrome
de ramsay hunt
comme vous pouvez le voir cet oeil ne
cligne pas je ne peux pas sourire de ce
côté du visage cette marine ne peut pas
bouger
c'est complètement paralysé de ce côté
de mon visage
pour ceux qui sont frustrés pour
l'annulation
de mai prochain concert
je ne suis juste physiquement évidemment
pas capable d'assurer mes concerts
j'espère que vous comprendrez et
je vais en profiter pour me reposer
qui se dit beaucoup c'est que quand il
est chez lui et qu'il ya du monde autour
ses agents ils arrivent dont sa femme
qui le calme ils arrivent à avoir une
vie mais des qui part en tournée à la
ctec lequel butent les stones c'est le
cas de britney spears dès qu'ils partent
en tournée qui l'ont entouré vie de
chien c'est l'acte et valais les
mauvaises personnes autour arrive ça se
décompose et il faut avoir une vie très
saine pour faire j'imagine une tournée
pareil whitney houston a dû arrêter et
là c'est pareil ils arrêtent des dab des
parts et psychologiquement parce que
sinon ils accueillent très étrange en
fait c'est surtout que ça touche
normalement des personnes à partir de 60
ans donc c'est bizarre que ça gueule si
jeune à qui les faits sans pouvoir
encore apparaître des dix ans avec
quelle 10 ans 20 ans du 8
pool à
la taille à l'entrée superflu régala
qu'il a tendance est
visiblement tombé sur le meilleur
c'est noir moi j'ai mal j'ai senti la
grand-mère ressenti le meilleur sur moi
toujours assumé par le chien ou le
playboy tout mais toujours toujours
toujours est ce que vous savez pourquoi
y avait des poules oui parfois c'était
un peu limite justement les poules
servait à faire des plans quand
justement la filiation établie mais
exactement et bad et que tout d'un coup
il pouvait se passer quelque chose d'un
peu sexuelle ou un peu ont focalisé sur
des poulets l'heure du conte à regarder
des poules benjamin avait des
indications de la production pendant les
prime pour orienter les votes c'est vrai
ça
quand même ces requêtes c'est pourquoi
les votes c'était pas du tout c'est un
sport lente et oui avec des produits